คำว่า quantum teleportation อาจฟังดูเหมือนเรื่องในนิยายวิทยาศาสตร์ แต่อย่างที่เราจะพูดถึงในตอนวันนี้
ของ Qiskit in the Classroom มันเป็นเทคนิคที่มีอยู่จริงและมีประโยชน์มากสำหรับการสื่อสารและ
เครือข่ายควอนตัม ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ Qiskit in the classroom ในซีรีส์นี้ เราจะใช้ Qiskit สำรวจแนวคิดพื้นฐานบาง
อย่างที่มักครอบคลุมในหลักสูตรที่เกี่ยวกับ quantum computing แต่ละวิดีโอมาพร้อมกับโมดูลเชิงโต้ตอบ
ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง อย่าลืมไปดูกัน Teleportation เป็น trope ในนิยายวิทยาศาสตร์และแฟนตาซีไปแล้ว
บุคคลหรือวัตถุหายไปจากสถานที่หนึ่งและปรากฏตัวทันทีที่อื่น
แม้จะเท่มาก แต่น่าเสียดายที่ teleportation แบบนั้นอย่างน้อยก็เป็นไปไม่ได้ มันจะทำลาย
ขีดจำกัดความเร็วของจักรวาล ไม่มีอะไรเดินทางเร็วกว่าแสงได้ แต่ quantum teleportation
เป็นไปได้ ใน quantum teleportation ข้อมูลแทนที่จะเป็นสสาร สามารถส่งระหว่างสอง
สถานที่ห่างไกล สิ่งที่ต้องการแค่คู่ qubit ที่ entangle กัน อันหนึ่งที่แต่ละสถานที่ และวิธีสื่อสาร classical
ข้อมูลระหว่างสองสถานที่ protocol นี้พัฒนาขึ้นในปี 1993 โดยทีม
นักวิทยาศาสตร์ควอนตัม รวมถึง Charles Bennett จาก IBM พวกเขาเรียกมันว่า quantum teleportation เพราะคล้ายกับ
เวอร์ชันนิยายวิทยาศาสตร์ ข้อมูลควอนตัมหายไปจากสถานที่หนึ่งและปรากฏในอีกสถานที่ห่างไกล
โดยไม่เคยเดินทางผ่านพื้นที่ระหว่างกัน มันอาจฟังดูเหมือนมายากล แต่อย่างที่เราจะเห็น ไม่มี
อะไรลึกลับหรือมหัศจรรย์เกี่ยวกับมันเลย มันเป็นไปได้ด้วยปรากฏการณ์ quantum entanglement ร่วมกับ
classical communication วันนี้เราจะอธิบาย quantum teleportation protocol และวิธีที่มันทำงาน แล้วจะนำมัน
ไปใช้จริงบน quantum computer เพื่อ teleport state ของ qubit จากด้านหนึ่งของ IBM quantum processor ไป
อีกด้านหนึ่ง นี่คือวิธีที่ quantum teleportation ทำงาน สมมุติว่ามีสองคน Alice กับ Bob ที่แยกจากกัน
ด้วยระยะทางไกล สมมุติว่า Alice มี qubit เราเรียก qubit Q แค่เพื่อความสะดวก และมันอยู่ใน
quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จัก sq โดย alpha 0 และ alpha 1 เป็น complex
number Alice อยากส่ง state ของตัวเองให้ Bob แต่ไม่มีทางส่ง qubit ตัวจริงได้ อาจเป็นเพราะ
เขาอยู่ไกลเกินไป หรืออาจเธอไม่รู้แน่ว่า Bob อยู่ที่ไหน ดังนั้นไม่รู้จะส่งไปที่ไหน โชคดีที่
เพื่อนทั้งสองมี qubit ที่ entangle กันอยู่แล้ว A และ B โดย Alice มี qubit A และ Bob มี qubit B และ
qubit เหล่านี้ entangle กัน โดย entangle หมายความว่าแม้ qubit สองตัวจะแยกจากกันด้วยระยะ
ทางไกล state ของมันยังสอดสัมพันธ์กันในลักษณะที่ฟิสิกส์คลาสสิกอธิบายไม่ได้ คู่ที่ entangle นี้
เรียกว่า Ebit ซึ่งเราใช้เป็น resource ใน quantum computing และ communication
ในกรณีนี้ Alice สามารถใช้ Ebit เป็น resource เพื่อส่งข้อมูลควอนตัมของเธอให้ Bob เพื่อดูว่าอย่างไร มา
เริ่มด้วยการเขียน joint state ของ qubit ทั้งสามตัวนี้ โดยเรียง qubit ค่อนข้างตามอำเภอใจ
ตอนนี้ แต่การเรียงนี้จะสะดวกเมื่อรันการทดลองบน Qiskit ใน Qiskit วิธีมาตรฐานในการ
เรียง qubit คือจากขวาไปซ้าย ดังนั้น state ของ qubit ศูนย์จะปรากฏทางขวา
มาขยาย state นิดหน่อยและเขียนใหม่แบบนี้ จากนั้นขั้นตอนแรกใน teleportation protocol คือ
ให้ Alice entangle data qubit ของเธอกับครึ่งหนึ่งของ Ebit qubit โดยใช้ C knot gate C knot หรือ controlled NOT
gate จะเปลี่ยน state ของ qubit หนึ่ง คือ target qubit ขึ้นอยู่กับ state ของ qubit อีกตัว คือ control qubit
ถ้า control qubit อยู่ใน state ศูนย์ ก็ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้นกับ target และถ้า control qubit อยู่ใน
state หนึ่ง target qubit จะ flip ดังนั้นในกรณีนี้ data qubit Q ของ Alice จะเป็น control qubit และ
Ebit qubit A ของเธอจะเป็น target qubit ดังนั้นสองพจน์แรกไม่เปลี่ยนเลยจาก C knot แต่
สองพจน์สุดท้ายเปลี่ยน เพราะ control qubit Q อยู่ใน state หนึ่ง จากนั้น Alice
จะใช้ Hadamard gate กับ data qubit Q ของเธอ ซึ่งนำ state 0 ไปยัง state 1 หาร root 2 คูณ 0 บวก 1 และ state 1 ไปยัง
1 หาร root 2 คูณ 0 ลบ 1 ฉันจะข้าม algebra ง่ายๆ ที่นี่ซึ่งคุณลองทำด้วยตัวเองได้ถ้าต้องการ
หลังจากจัดเรียง term ใหม่จะได้ state ที่มีลักษณะแบบนี้ ตอนนี้ three qubit ที่
entangle กันของ Alice และ Bob ดูยุ่งเหยิงมาก แต่ดูสิว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้า Alice วัด qubit ทั้งสองของเธอ สาม
qubit state จะ collapse บางส่วนเป็นหนึ่งในสี่
term เหล่านี้ และในแต่ละกรณี Bob จะเหลือ superposition state ที่มี amplitude สัมพันธ์กับ Alice
initial state ที่ไม่รู้จัก จำไว้ว่า amplitude คือ alpha 0 และ alpha 1 ดังนั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า Alice วัด qubit ทั้งสองเป็นศูนย์ state ของ Bob จะ collapse เป็น term นี้ นั่นคือ
state เดิมที่ไม่รู้จักที่ Alice ต้องการ teleport แต่ถ้า Alice วัดศูนย์บน qubit A และหนึ่งบน qubit Q state ของ Bob
จะเป็นอันนี้ state นี้สามารถแปลงเป็น state เดิมของ qubit Q ได้ถ้า Bob
ใช้ Z gate ซึ่งจะ flip เครื่องหมายตรงนี้ แต่ Bob จะไม่รู้ว่าต้องทำสิ่งนี้
จนกว่าเขาจะรู้ว่า Alice วัดได้อะไร ดังนั้นขั้นตอนต่อไปใน protocol คือให้ Alice โทรหา Bob และบอกว่า
วัดได้อะไร หลังจากที่รู้แล้ว เขาก็รู้ว่าต้องทำ operation อะไรกับ qubit ของตัวเองเพื่อให้ตรงกับ
state เดิมของ Alice นี่คือตารางของการวัดสี่แบบที่เป็นไปได้และ operation สี่แบบที่ Bob
ต้องทำกับ qubit ของตัวเองตามการวัดเหล่านั้น Bob อาจต้องทำ Z gate, X gate หรือทั้งคู่เพื่อ
แปลง qubit ของตัวเองให้ตรงกับ qubit เดิมของ Alice ขั้นตอนสุดท้ายที่ Alice โทรหา Bob นี้คือเหตุผลที่
quantum teleportation ไม่ละเมิด causality แม้ว่า state ของ Bob collapse ทันทีเมื่อ Alice วัด
qubit ของเธอ Bob ก็ไม่สามารถดึงข้อมูลออกจาก state นั้นได้จนกว่า Alice จะบอกว่าวัดอะไร และ
การโทรนั้นถูกจำกัดด้วยความเร็วแสง เราเพิ่งผ่านคณิตศาสตร์ละเอียดมาก ดังนั้นข้อเท็จจริงที่เหลือเชื่อ
ว่าเราเพิ่ง teleport ข้อมูลควอนตัมไปอาจหายไปในความสับสน แต่มันน่าทึ่งมากจริงๆ โดยการใช้
entanglement เป็น resource Alice สามารถวัดเพื่อทำลายข้อมูลควอนตัมที่เก็บไว้กับเธอและให้มัน
ปรากฏในอีกสถานที่ห่างไกลกับ Bob ระยะทางนี้อาจหลายร้อยหรือพันกิโลเมตร ยิ่งน่าทึ่งกว่านั้น
protocol นี้ไม่ต้องการให้ Alice รู้ว่า Bob อยู่ที่ไหนด้วยซ้ำ ตราบที่พวกเขามี Ebit
ร่วมกันและสามารถสื่อสาร classical กันได้ quantum teleportation จะทำงานได้ ตอนนี้มาดูวิธีที่มันทำงาน
ด้วย Qiskit และ teleport quantum state จริงๆ บน quantum computer
เราจะเริ่มด้วย qubit สามตัว อันหนึ่งสำหรับ data qubit Q และ qubit A กับ B ที่จะเป็น Ebit เรา
เริ่มด้วยการสร้าง Ebit เราใช้ Hadamard กับ qubit A ตามด้วย C knot
ระหว่าง A และ B เพื่อสร้าง entangled state ที่ต้องการ
จากนั้นเตรียม qubit Q ของ Alice ใน quantum state สุ่มโดยใช้ random unitary ที่แสดงด้วยกล่องนี้ที่ระบุว่า
U แล้วก็มาถึง teleportation อย่างแรก C knot ระหว่าง qubit Q กับ A แล้ว Hadamard กับ
qubit Q จากนั้นการวัด collapse state บางส่วนเพื่อให้แค่ qubit B ของ Bob อยู่ใน superposition
ตรงนี้คือจุดที่ Alice จะโทรหา Bob และบอกว่าวัดได้อะไร จากนั้น Bob จะใช้
gate ขึ้นอยู่กับการวัดเหล่านั้น กล่องที่มีเส้นขอบสีแดงแสดงถึง conditional gate ตัวแรกหมายความว่า
Bob ใช้ X gate กับ qubit ของตัวเองถ้า qubit A ถูกวัดเป็นหนึ่ง และ
ตัวที่สองหมายความว่าเขาจะใช้ Z gate ด้วยถ้า qubit Q ถูกวัดเป็นหนึ่ง
ตอนนี้ Bob ควรมี qubit ใน state เดียวกับที่ qubit ของ Alice อยู่ ณ จุดนี้หลังจาก unitary gate
ถ้าทุกอย่างเป็นไปตามแผน เราก็ teleport quantum state แล้ว แต่จะตรวจสอบได้อย่างไร เรารัน
circuit เดิมแต่เปลี่ยนเล็กน้อยหนึ่งอย่าง
ตรงนี้เราเพิ่ม unitary อีกตัวที่ปลาย circuit ที่ใช้กับ qubit ของ Bob unitary นี้คือ inverse ของ
อันที่ใช้ตอนต้นกับ qubit ของ Alice เหตุผลคือถ้า gate แรกนี้สร้าง
quantum state ที่ตอนนี้ teleport ไปยัง qubit ของ Bob gate นี้ควรยกเลิกมัน นำ qubit ของ Bob กลับสู่ state
ศูนย์ แต่แน่นอน การทำสิ่งนี้ยกเลิกงานที่ทำมาทั้งหมดเรื่อง teleportation ดังนั้นไม่ควรทำ
ถ้าต้องการใช้งาน state ที่ teleport จริงๆ และถ้ามันอยู่ใน quantum state ที่ไม่รู้จักจริงๆ
เราไม่สามารถใช้ unitary เพื่อยกเลิกมันได้ อย่างไรก็ตาม นี่เป็นแค่เพื่อวินิจฉัยเพื่อ
ตรวจสอบว่า teleportation สำเร็จ ถ้าเราวัด qubit ของ Bob อยู่ใน state ศูนย์ เราก็มั่นใจได้ในระดับหนึ่งว่า
teleportation ทำงาน เมื่อแน่ใจว่า protocol ทำงานตามที่คาดไว้ เราก็เอา
unitary สุดท้ายออกและทำอะไรกับ state ที่ teleport ได้จริงๆ แต่ตอนนี้แค่ตรวจสอบว่ามันทำงานก่อน มา
รัน circuit บน quantum computer เราใช้ Qiskit primitive sampler เพื่อรัน circuit นี้
หลายครั้งและรวบรวมสถิติเกี่ยวกับผลลัพธ์การวัด ถ้าเรา teleport state ของ Alice ไปยัง Bob ได้สมบูรณ์แบบ
ทุกครั้ง Bob จะวัด qubit ของตัวเองเป็นศูนย์ทุกครั้ง แต่ด้วย noise จากสิ่งแวดล้อมและความไม่สมบูรณ์ใน
gate เราคาดว่าจะเห็นบางรอบที่ qubit ของ Bob เป็นหนึ่ง แต่ตราบที่ส่วนใหญ่
qubit ของ Bob ถูกวัดเป็นศูนย์ เราเรียกมันว่าสำเร็จ ตรงนี้มี histogram ของผลลัพธ์การวัดของ
qubit ทั้งสามตัว การวัดของ Bob แสดงในตำแหน่งแรกของแต่ละ three-bit string ตามที่คาดไว้ สี่
ผลลัพธ์ที่ตรงกับ bit ของเขาเป็นศูนย์มีโอกาสมากกว่าอีกสี่ตัว ดังนั้น เราสำเร็จ
teleport quantum state แล้ว แต่ดูว่าเรา teleport ไปไกลแค่ไหน นี่คือแผนที่ของ
qubit ทั้งหมดบน quantum processor ที่ใช้ และในการทดลอง เราใช้แค่สาม qubit นี้
qubit ของ Alice อยู่ที่นี่และ qubit ของ Bob อยู่ที่นี่ ดังนั้นพวกมันอยู่ใกล้กันมาก เราสามารถ
ทำสิ่งเดียวกันได้โดยใช้ swap gate สองสาม gate ซึ่งอย่างที่ชื่อบอก แค่สลับ quantum state
ของ qubit เพื่อนบ้านสองตัว Quantum teleportation มีประโยชน์สำหรับการขนส่งข้อมูลควอนตัมระยะไกล และ
quantum state ถูก teleport ระยะหลายร้อยกิโลเมตรมาก่อน สำหรับการทดลองของเราที่นี่ ถูกจำกัดโดย
ขนาดของ chip แต่เราทำให้ teleportation น่าประทับใจขึ้นได้โดย teleport state ระหว่างสอง
qubit ที่ห่างกันบน quantum computer ของเรา มาลองดู นี่คือ circuit diagram ใหม่ มันดู
ซับซ้อนกว่านิดหน่อย แต่ไม่มีอะไรเปลี่ยนแปลงพื้นฐาน ยกเว้นว่าตอนนี้ Alice กับ Bob สร้าง Ebit ร่วมกัน
แล้วแยกกัน ชุดเส้นและ X เหล่านี้แสดง swap gate ซึ่งย้าย
state ของ Alice และ Bob จาก qubit หนึ่งไปอีก qubit Alice ย้ายขึ้นไปยัง qubit 1 และ
Bob ย้ายลงไปยัง qubit 12 แล้ว Alice สร้าง state สุ่มของเธอบน qubit 0 ด้วย
unitary นี้ จำไว้ว่าเธอสร้าง state หลังจากที่เธอกับ Bob แยกกันไปแล้ว
ดังนั้น Bob อยู่ห่างจากเธอไปแล้ว
แล้ว teleportation protocol ดำเนินต่อไปตามเดิมและ Bob ได้รับ state เดิมของ Alice หลังจาก
conditional operations ของเขา เราใช้ inverse unitary gate แล้วตรวจสอบว่า qubit ของ Bob
อยู่ใน state ศูนย์ และอีกครั้งเราเห็นว่าส่วนใหญ่ qubit ของ Bob พบว่าอยู่ใน state
ศูนย์ ดังนั้น teleportation สำเร็จ
อัตราความสำเร็จไม่สูงเท่าตอนที่ Alice กับ Bob อยู่ใกล้กัน swap gate ทั้งหมดนั้น
แพงและทำให้ Ebit เสื่อมลงนิดหน่อย Quantum teleportation อาจดูเหมือนมายากล แต่อย่างที่เราได้
เห็น สิ่งที่ต้องการแค่ entanglement ช่องทางสื่อสาร classical และความฉลาด ข้อเสนอเดิมปี 1993
ที่เราพูดถึงในวิดีโอนี้เป็นรากฐานของ protocol อื่นๆ เช่น quantum gate
teleportation และเป็นส่วนประกอบสำคัญสำหรับ quantum computation และการสื่อสาร
ในด้านการทดลอง นักวิทยาศาสตร์ยังคงผลักดันขอบเขตของ quantum teleportation แม้แต่ทำการ teleport
quantum state ของโฟตอนระหว่างห้องแล็บบนโลกและดาวเทียมที่ระยะ 1,400 กิโลเมตร
เหนือมัน และ teleport quantum state ผ่านสาย internet คลาสสิกที่มี noise ถ้าต้องการ teleport
quantum state ของตัวเอง ไปที่โมดูล quantum teleportation ที่ลิงก์ในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง ขอบคุณที่รับชม
แล้วเจอกันครั้งหน้า